[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on Thursday 9th of
November I'm Cindy you the spectators
assistant editor and your host this week
coming up on the show the pro Palestine
marches will return this Saturday the
biggest yet organizer say what is at
stake with allowing these protests to go
ahead on arm mr's day counter extremism
expert Ian hon and writer Joanna
Williams join me to
discuss and while the world's attention
is on Gaza what about the West Bank
that's the question the philosopher
slavo xek raises in this week's magazine
and he joins the show to talk about how
the West Bank could provide a way out of
this conflict if only netanyahu's
government would see the light we also
continue to cover the co inquiry with
Revelations this week that the second
lockdown may have been decided on false
information our data editor Michael
Simmons joins the
show and finally what problems lie ahead
with the rise of porn made cheaply and
quickly by AI our columnist Sam leth has
written about this and he joins the show
alongside spectator contributor and anti
porn campaigner Julie bindle before we
get going if you like spectator TV do
subscribe to our YouTube channel
thousands are joining our Channel every
week and you should be one of them just
click the Subscribe button at the bottom
of this video and tap the Bell icon so
you never never miss an episode and
thank you to our sponsors canac cord
genuity wealth management canac cord are
experienced wealth planners and
investment managers who offer unwavering
support during challenging times to find
out more visit cow wealth.com for more
information first up for the cover piece
this week counter extremism expert and
former prisons Governor Ian hon looks at
the politics of policing protests the
Met are allowing the protest to go ahead
on Saturday but can they handle what
will be the biggest marches yet Ian is
with me now alongside the writer Joanna
Williams who looks at the Met's
inconsistencies on The Spectators Coffee
House blog this
week Ian and Joanna thank you so much
for joining spectator TV now Ian I want
to start with that Suella bravman
article in the times from Wednesday
night um in a peace lambasting the Met
for being biased in the way at police's
protest she says and I quote I do not
believe that these marches are merely a
cry for help for Gaza they are an
assertion of Primacy by groups
particularly islamists of the kind we
are more used to seeing in Northern
Ireland what do you make of
that well quite a lot uh frankly coming
from Northern Ireland um I think it was
a pretty unwise analogy to draw she's
probably managed to do what's almost
impossible in Northern Ireland that is
unite uh two communities in in
condemnation um because the implication
The Wider implication of what she's
saying is that you know um civil rights
marches or orange order marches
are are equivalent to you know Hamas
supporting marches of course she didn't
mean that she was talking uh I I hope in
a much narrower way about the
commemoration uh of of terrorism within
some marches in northernland which
absolutely does take place particularly
in paramilitary funerals uh but at the
same time I I I think that was an
unfortunate uh comparison to draw um and
it takes away from you know the the um
uh absolutely legitimate points that
that she has been making that these
marches are infiltrated by people who've
got virulently anti-semitic uh opinions
and and my my view was uh in the uh
spectator piece I I wrote yesterday for
the magazine that uh you know Mark roley
has now said he can guarantee that there
will be an assertive policing operation
uh over the weekend uh and particularly
around um the the armist two-minute
silence and he needs to be held to
account for that uh so you know it's a
very big test for the met I hope they're
up for it but uh you know home
secretaries are entitled to talk about
policing and she is reflecting a you
know a widely held public perception
that the police are too soft on these
marches and we have to see an assertive
presence where that you know existing
laws are enforced that's the key thing
it's not about needing new laws and I
think Mark rley if I if I might say um
went a bit off script as well when he he
seemed to be complaining that you know
he didn't have enough laws to to enforce
there's there's absolutely there's
public order legislation and there's
racial and religious hate uh legislation
that needs to be seen to be enforced not
you know 2 weeks after the event but
immediately to give back confidence that
London is being protected and policed
without fear or
favor now Ian at a time of filming Mark
Ry has said that the protest will still
be going ahead on Saturday do you think
he's made the right call there well I
think the bar for Banning a protest is
extremely high and necessarily so I mean
uh the right for peaceful assembly and
protest is is a you know very a very
precious one and it's protected by uh
legislation and there's there's you know
um very high bar for for that being
interfered with and and rightly so
because it's a it's a pressure valve uh
and apart from lots of other things uh
to be able to allow a peaceful process
to take part in this country and
ironically one of the things we
celebrate in remembrance weekend is the
fact that to many people fought and died
from the UK and across the Empire uh so
you know I I think it would take a lot
for for him to be able to say that he
has Intelligence that suggests there
would be serious uh risk to public life
or public disorder uh for for him to ask
the Home Secretary to to ban it so on
the basis of what we know I think he's
applied the law correctly but I I go
back to my original point this is a
massive test for S Mark and for his men
and women who'll be on the front line
this weekend and we must see that uh the
uh parade uh the the the uh Armistice
two- minutes silence and the parade that
happens quite a long time after it is
properly and professionally and
assertively policed Joanna would you
agree with that because um for The
Spectators website coffee house this
week you've also written about the
inconsistency in the way in which the
Met have policed these Pro Palestine
protests compared to let's say the sah
everal indivuals I mean this is also a
point that so Braven has made yeah I
think we can see some quite big
discrepancies to be clear though I I
absolutely think the Marchers should be
allowed to go ahead you know I agree
with Ian on that I completely disagree
with the Marchers um I think that there
are lots of problems with the Marchers
but I think if you want to live in a
country that supports freedom of speech
um supports the right for people to
protest uh then you cannot stop marches
going ahead simply because you don't
agree with the um principles the of the
protesters and Jonah just looking at the
Met as well something else you point out
in your piece uh is this former advisor
for the Met attic Malik can you tell us
about him and why it's important uh you
know that his
story so um attic Mal attic Malik is a
prop Palestinian supporter who uh has a
long history of act ISM uh he's Al he's
a lawyer U from Luton but he um has a
long history of working with the Muslim
Community and advancing causes close to
the heart of members of that Community
um which in this instance involves being
a prop Palestine he has spoken at a prop
Palestinian rally um when Israel was
involved in a conflict in Gaza a couple
of years ago and he was filmed um making
the chant leading crowds in the Chant uh
of from The River To The Sea and also
making comments which have been um about
kind of Zionist control of the media um
me as an explanation as to why more
press coverage wasn't being given uh to
his side of the argument and this
comment is being widely interpreted as
being
anti-semitic now to me uh that doesn't
seem like a suitable person to have
advising for policing um it it just
seems like a very simple straightforward
Google search would reveal this
information and I personally don't think
that this is somebody if I was involved
in the policing of a of a March that
this is the type of person who I would
think would be suitable to have or or
kind of somebody who I could trust to
give an objective neutral balanced
nonpartisan um viewpoint on what was
happening particularly when you're under
pressure to make very quick spof the
moment
decisions uh and yet clearly somebody at
the Met uh thought that attic Malik was
just the right kind of person to have in
the control room observing the protest
and offering minute by minute advice or
potent
we we we we don't know we don't know
what his role was we just know he was
there as an observer um this was the day
that uh people in the crowds were were
spotted chatting chanting Jihad and the
Met ISU a statement um explaining that
the word Jihad has many different
definitions uh and we need to be
sympathetic in our
interpretation of of how that word was
being used now we don't know clearly we
don't know whether Malik was the person
who um provided those different
definitions of jihad and and kind of
said that this wasn't a cause to arrest
someone um but the very fact that he was
present in the room when that decision
was being made um means that that this
suspicion hangs over the policing of the
event incredible um Ian you know you're
former prison's Governor you have seen
um what it's like to have crowd control
issues to have work for large
institutions public institutions what do
you think can explain this episode when
it comes to the met you know how can
they basically not know who their senior
advisers are and whether or not they're
impartial well it's an extraordinary
feeling but I'm afraid it's not
surprising if you look at the
organization that Mark rugley um
inherited um it is you uh Riven with
dysfunction and I think that dysfunction
extends to a senior command level where
you will have you know gold command
control rooms festooned with human
rights advisers who seem to take
priority over public order policing uh
so I think the balance has has got out
of kilter and and with that uh you know
the tolerance of having people who who
are you know completely unsuitable for
for giving advice uh like uh Mr Malik
clearly uh is be becomes wider and wider
and I think there's a there's a broader
issue that I bang on about all the time
in social media which I would call
institutional
timidity and it's a sort of uh infection
that I think is spreading across uh
Public Services particularly uniform
Public Services where there seems to be
more and more um of a reluctance to be
able to confront particularly hateful
Behavior Uh in the interests of of some
sort of spirous uh Community um uh um
views or or um based on very
unrepresentative views that are that
that are put out there by by you know
Community Representatives so-call
so you know I think the Met needs to get
back to a policing operation this
weekend and needs to realize that you
know this is a seminal moment as I said
in my piece for the Metropolitan Police
and Mar rley and and in fact you could
take it broader and say for the rule of
law because thousands and hundreds of
thousands of people people who aren't at
those marches have looked on with total
dismay at the way that you know virulent
anti-Semitism seems to have free rein uh
you know we we've got a a tiny minority
of people uh Jewish people in this
country one of the smallest religious
minorities in in the country many of
them are terrified to go into our
capital city in a weekend because they
meet these malevolent marches that seem
to be asserting their dominance and and
uh uh you know their their utter
impunity to do whatever they like and go
whatever they like we've got to draw
some lines in the sand here and it's
done to the police to do that so you
know again there is a massive test here
and if Mark Ry fails that test and he
has um said he will deliver
an effective and asserting policing uh
operation this weekend I I I think then
we need to ask really fundamental
questions uh about you our our values
and how they may be being eroded from
From the Inside by marches of such uh
impunity that are taking place um you
know and are likely to continue to take
place for events that are you know
thousands of miles away I agree with
with what I just said but uh I'm not
sure I completely think that timidity is
the only explanation for what's going on
here um I actually think that the police
along with perhaps a number of other
institutions in our society have become
almost a little bit confused about what
their core purpose is um particularly in
as regards to large demonstrations and
demonstrations of a political nature um
I think some of the values if you like
that are dominant amongst perhaps the
the equity diversity and inclusion
officers or or kind of values uh that
that have been taken on board by the
police a as core values Central to their
mission as well so then when they meet
protesters who actually appear to share
the values that they've been told are
important I think that creates some
sense of confusion around what what the
actual role of a police is I mean how do
you arrest people when it's a cause that
that you have been told you should um
have some sympathy with whether that's
coming from the College of policing or
perhaps coming from some of the
membership organizations within the
campaign or coming from the EDI training
that officer officers are expected to in
uh to to partake in I think it creates
this this confusion about core purpose I
think for example if you have um a lot
of of worry I mean and perhaps for good
reason worry about being perceived as
being racist or you're worried about
being perceived as
islamophobic um then your approach is
going to be far different than if your
main concern is is worry about being
anti-semitic or um purely and simply
worry about upholding the law in the
most objective and neutral way possible
a big test indeed for S Mark rally um
Joanna Williams and Ian hon thank you so
much for joining spectator
TV next the philosopher slavo xek writes
for the magazine this week about the
depths of Despair for Palestinians not
just in Gaza but also in the West Bank
he argues that it is not justifying or
excusing violence to look at the context
of the conflict more widely slavo joins
me
now slav welcome to spectator TV now in
The Spectator this week you highlight
the despair of Palestinians not just in
Gaza but within the West Bank as well
now many have sought to explain the
Hamas attacks within the context of
occupation and Colonial struggle now in
your view as a philosopher does this
despair ever justify violence of any
kind and in your article you try to give
this context but does that mean that
you're excusing or justifying this
violence
yourself look my position was here very
clear because I was accused yes that I
in a more refined Twisted way that I
somehow justify the Hamas violence and
then the idea was even no at this tragic
moment we don't speak about a complex
city is just we should be shocked at
what happened I
agree absolutely but there is a b but
let's take I took the example of Hitler
my god there are dozens of books
explaining the background which was the
confused situation of suffering of
ordinary jours and so on that was
exploited by Hitler by the Nazis to grab
power and it's for me a similar thing
that has to be done with the Hamas
attack I
unconditionally condemn it I even wrote
Israel has no only not only the right to
defend itself but also the right to
annihilate
Hamas but what really worries me is that
Hamas on the Palestinian side and the
present government of Israel on the
Israeli side are really doing something
that one cannot but but call following
that metaphor you know it takes two to
tango these are two radical stances I'm
not equalizing them in the sense of uh
evil and so on but nonetheless these are
two comparable stances in the sense that
each of them wants to get rid of
annihilate the enemy Hamas said clearly
kill the Jews the Jews should be thrown
out the Jews don't belong here the
hardliners around Netanyahu are saying
the same this is primarily our land it's
exclusively Our Land where does this
leave Palestinians of course it is
pushing him to P sorry it is pushing
them to despair so I even went a step
further and said that from habas we got
a totally
inexcusable violent attack but from the
uh other side look for me it's more
crucial than Gaza look what is now
happening on the West Bank it's what one
cannot but call gradual ethnic
cleansing with constant violence of
settlers against Palestinians there and
it's not just a gentle violence people
are killed Beat to Death and so on and
it's not something that is that happened
now after October the 7 it's going on
permanently
and even the United
States voiced their serious concern
about this so what I am afraid is that
both extreme sides hardliners in Israeli
government and Hamas are in some sense
echoing each other and objectively not
subjectively I'm not a conspiracy
theorist they are uh supporting each
other let's face it the inexcusable
attack on Gaza
served the government of Israel
perfectly to divert attention from what
is going on on the West Bank and to
proceed with much greater speed now
towards gradual ethnic cleansing
sorry slavo what do you mean the the the
inexcusable attack on Gaza do you mean
the the October 7th attacks on no no
sorry I meant sorry the Hamas attack yes
yes yes yeah yeah to be clear here which
uh again this is not as I was often
accused this is not just a formal
condemnation so that I can then proceed
to Israel bashing no I knew people who
new people in who were slaughtered by
Hamas there as we all know the Paradox
is that these were people who
were absolutely open to Palestinians
having the Jewish settlers who were
slaughtered having contact with Gaza all
the time helping Gaza and so on and so
on so the message of Hamas attack was
clear they were not killed because they
stood for the worst of Israeli militaris
no they were peac loving Jews they were
killed and the message was no peace with
Jews War to the end so again I have no
Illusions here about Hamas it's a
fundamentalist terrorist
organization but I I think here problems
emerge that what is going on on the West
Bank especially for years now this
constant pressure and you can find
numerous
podcasts on uh on YouTube and so on
because Palestinians also have iPhones
and so on which make you
sick settlers protected even supported
by Israeli police and military units
terrorized Focus for example on a
Palestinian uh uh household on a farm
threaten them beat them also killed them
after October 7th only
over50 Palestinians were killed in such
operations and Israel does nothing so
here is the tragedy for me how both
sides raise tension of course by
endlessly showing repeating this images
of the horrors of the Hamas attack which
Israel of course yes the full right to
do Israel what I'm afraid it is doing is
that instead of using this as a unique
chance of Peace instead of sending to
pales Ians Hamas is out but now here is
what we offer you on the West Bank at
least no they are using this
to to raise to a higher level the brutal
tension putting pushing Palestinians
there into Despair and what worries me
at least as much as this and here I
simply rationally don't understand what
is Israel is doing it is that by this
inexcusably brutal attack on Gaza yes
Hamas has to be annihilated but the way
Israel is doing it with
exploding numbers of socalled collateral
damage children and so on can you even
imagine
what this is doing to anti semitism what
a new Boost this is giving to
anti-Semitism how is it possible to
annihilate Hamas as you say in Gaza
without when when it's such a densely
populated area and we do suspect that
Gaza that Hamas has a crucial
infrastructure under civilian
infrastructure in tunnels in Gaza you
know if you're in the Israeli government
how is it possible to annihilate Hamas
as you say without that kind of casualty
I mean we now see that that kind of
bombardment has allowed Ground Forces to
go into and Surround Gaza City without
it the IDF couldn't be doing what it's
doing right
now oh no I I mean I know I'm not saying
it's an easy solution but and but to do
it a little bit more not gradually in
the sense of prolonging it for months
and so on but uh okay let me give you
one example you remember now it must be
already two three weeks ago when Israel
for the first time
po gave 24hour TR to citizens of
Northern Gaza of the Gaza City to move
South now wasn't this an absolutely
absurd proposal 1.2 million people many
of them in hospitals pregnant women and
so on cannot simply move to our outside
how how should this be done so what I'm
saying is uh yes one has to destroy
Hamas but isn't there also a limit to
so-called
collateral
damage there should be a way which I
find even relatively easy
to to to imagine for example okay you
surround Gaza then you establish slowly
safety corridors where of course you
check people and so on there is a
whole network of procedures which could
be done I think it's which could which
could make the operation much more human
otherwise isn't it a little bit too
simple okay I don't trust the
Palestinian numbers but for sure uh uh
many more people died in Gaza than in
than uh in the Israeli attack I uh and
on the other hand I agree that the
situation is complex how Hamas is in a
tfing way using every people as a shield
and so on and so on but isn't there
nonetheless a limit to
saying okay we killed one terrorist and
I don't know what would be the number 34
innocent Palestinians children de are
just a collateral damage it's a too easy
solution for me in a in a more gradual
way it could have been done you're the
philosopher sorry you're the philosopher
here and what you're you know you're
talking about this kind of calculus of
how much lives are worth what do you
think what should be guiding what is the
balance to be struck here when you've
got these objectives and I I hear what
you're saying about the Netanyahu
government and I think a lot of liberal
secular Israelis before October 7th
would have agreed with you on
disagreeing with netanyahu's government
but what is the balance to be struck you
are you providing answers
here s are you providing answers in
terms of how yes in terms of
how with but why this is already typical
why do we focus on
Gaza I think the real thing now is
happening on the West Bank much
intensified what what one cannot but
call ethnic cleansing there why Israel
one way for Israel to provide a
different message to Palestinians would
be to stop the ethnic cleansing on the
West Bank and to show that another way
time to give sorry to show that another
way is possible yeah yeah yeah this is
the only way for me to fully justify and
it can be justified the attack on Gaza
at the same time you have to show
exactly the Palestinians there is
another way or as somebody who certainly
cannot be accused of being pramas yal
Noah Harari said we have to offer
Palestinians who don't support Terror
who are not anti-semitic we have to
offer them a clear way how to live
freely and in a dignify weight in their
own Homeland this is the term used by
Harari or look at what for example uh uh
other Israeli politicians more liberal
have said that the key the underlying
tension is the unresolved Palestinian
question on the one hand I don't buy
thiso leftist version of what Israel is
doing there is simply
neocolonialism colonizing a country no
Jewish people have a certain a certain
right to the land but not exclusive
right but so do Palestinians the only
way to resolve again the point is now
from the site of Israel to offer
Palestinians a clear hope not just to
put pressure on them and again I agree
with you it is problematic to uh to to
set a clear limmit how much collateral
damage and so on and so on I'm only
saying obviously it could should have
been possible to do it in a better more
considerate way if for no other reason
for the incredible damage that this is
doing to to juice all
around can you imagine what impression
this constant images of children being
killed in Gaza and so on and so on what
they what they will do to the explosion
of anti semitism slav ja I'm afraid
that's all we have time for thank you so
much for joining spectator
TV the co inquiry continues this week
but missed by baroness halet is a
shocking Revelation in the written
testimony of a former number 10 adviser
it raises an important question did a
second lockdown happen on a false
premise justified by a model that had
already been proven wrong did the
government knowingly mislead the public
Michael Simmons our data editor writes
about the story in this week's issue and
he joins spectator TV now but first
let's revisit what happened in that
Monumental press conference on October
31st 2020 where a second lockdown was
announced the modeling group asked a
number of academic groups to create
scenarios as to what might happen on
assumptions that ask stays above 1 and
goes between 1.3 1.5 and possibly up
over the course of the winter and the
next slide shows the early working from
two weeks ago of some of those groups
looking at deaths in England over the
winter period Michael joins me on the
show now so Michael this graph was torn
apart in the days after the press
conference called out by statisticians
already so what first of all what is the
problem with the graph so basically the
graph
overestimated the um the peak of deaths
and that was because the r number that
was fed into the models and just to
remind people the r numberers the
reproduction rate of the virus was
basically too high now the reason that
was spotted so quickly um there was
various pieces about it the stats
Authority ended up criticizing it was
because you could already plug in the
actuals for the days leading up to that
press conference and they were already
you know way
overestimated and at the time it was
just f that this was a fumble by
government this was a mistake this was a
model that hadn't been properly
scrutinized but it looks like from Ben
Warner's evidence that actually it
wasn't a fumble they knew that this
graph was wrong but used it anyway right
and that's what your piece is about this
week not about the graph being wrong but
what they know knew when and so first of
all just tell us who is Ben Warner why
is it important what he has to say so
Ben Warner was brought into um number 10
Downing Street the day after the
election win and he was going to be the
basically the chief spad in in charge of
data and digital and very quickly
because of his data expertise he ended
up heavily involved in the coid um
response for much of 2020 so Ben Warner
was involved in in basically he acted
sort of as a channel between Sage he
attended Sage on behalf of Dominick
Cummings and he would report what was
being said in Sage back to those
officials in number 10 and that's
basically exactly what happened here
with this graph he spotted this graph he
screenshotted it and started to
circulate it within number 10 so that's
where kind of this graph comes from
right but at the time someone did warn
government already that this graph was
wrong and that's where Angela McLean
comes in is that right yes absolutely so
Ben himself um started to realize when
he' looked at de's data that maybe um
there was there was something wrong with
this graph he also noted that it wasn't
um it hadn't gone through Sage or spym
so it hadn't been officially signed off
then on the day of that the lockdown was
announced so that Halloween day he had a
phone call with Angela mlan who
basically flagged that new data had been
looked at that showed that as we're
saying earlier that our number was lower
and that the peak was probably going to
be about half of the level that was
actually showing on that on that graph
so Ben Warner finished that phone call
went straight into the cabinet room
according to his evidence and flagged to
the Prime Minister and other officials
that this graph was wrong and shouldn't
be used in the press conference
incredible and this is in his written
test monial right so so what he's
actually saying is that he warned people
in government about this wrong graph so
they knew absolutely so Ben says that
you know not just that he knew and then
flagged it to the Prime Minister and his
officials but other people Angela mlan
um a chap from the government's office
for science knew that this graph
shouldn't be used so multiple officials
um knew that it was wouldn't be used but
Ben's Ben Warner actually goes further
in his evidence that after he left the
cabinet room having flagged the issues
with the graph he was under the
impression that it was not going to be
used I think he'd agreed with Angela
mlan that they were going to use this
reasonable worst case scenario instead a
different one which was a lot closer to
what actually ended up happening so he
left um it left work for that day
thinking that he'd you know squashed
this graph and it wasn't going to be
used he'd done his job but then he says
you know it wasn't until it went on TV
that he discovered that no the graph was
used that is so shocking and but but Al
what's also shocking is the fact that
Ben Warner has been up against the co
inquiry this week talking to baroness
Hallet but this question wasn't one that
she asked him so you had you spotted
this in the written data yeah so um the
there's two kind of sections of evidence
in the inquiry so there's what you say
in the hearings and then there's the
statements which every um witness gives
um and I should just sort of shout out
Oliver Johnson who's a professor that
occasionally writes for us he kind of
spotted this um originally and alerted
us to it um and basically this was in
you know Midway through his EV his
evidence document where he goes into the
section about how the the second
lockdown came about and the inquiry
cases um basically didn't go down that
line of questioning because they don't
seem to be interested in finding out of
the really the decisions behind lockdown
it's a lot more was lockdown too late
who was swearing on WhatsApp so that
didn't come up in the spoken parts of
the inquiry that presents a spe specific
problem for journalists and the public
because Ben Warner's evidence in this
section references you know the slides
the emails the discussions about this
graph but we able to see them because
the way public inquiries are set up you
can only see the evidence that's spoken
about or shown in the actual hearings so
the actual emails um where he's
discussing these graphs we can only take
his word for it they won't be released
unless he's either called back to the
inquiry or baroness halet decides to
include it in her report and unless the
inquiry questions those involved at the
time we won't know why it was the
government went ahead and released the
graph that they knew seemed to have been
warned was wrong I mean we don't know
exactly what Patrick Valance is uh role
was in all of this how much he and Chris
buty knew but Ben Warner says that he
warned some people in government at
least and but we'll never know what that
process is because inquir is not asking
about it yep exactly so we cannot see
the email that um Ben Warner references
in uh in his written statement unless um
it is specifically shown in an inquiry
hearing so they would either have to
call him or others back to go over that
or and baress halet can look at it
herself and include it in her final
report but if that's the case it's going
to be years before we you know get to
the truth of this W it's incredible I
mean obviously the inquiry has so much
like a trove of evidence to go through
for everyone so you can imagine maybe
they just missed it but what do you
think this says about the inquiry itself
you know you kind of already hinted at
it when it comes to what the focus the
emphasis really is of the inquiry yeah I
I think this is another problem I mean
look the inquiry cas's and baroness
Hallet they've got a huge um task on
their hands because there is just so
much to go through I mean every witness
is submitting like 90 page statements
and you you know they're only there for
a few hours to be questioned so you
can't ask them about everything but a
lot of the inquiry that I've watched
seems to be focused on what I would
personally say is you know quite trivial
number 10 personalities what was said on
WhatsApp I mean just an example of one
thing they did ask Ben Warner about
rather than this was um there was some
WhatsApp where someone had said that Ben
Warner was screaming this piece of
information and Ben Warner was asked if
the screaming was literal or
metaphorical I mean like what relevance
is that
so to me the inquiry just seems to have
the wrar at the moment very concerning
but also Michael grateful to you for
following it Michael Simmons thank you
so much thank
you and finally AI generated pornography
is rapidly On The Rise according to
researchers you could as some American
teenage boys did recently put the faces
of the women that you know on sexually
explicit content and for it to look very
real indeed The Spectator Sam leth has
written about this for coffee house this
week and in an industry wrapped up in
sexual exploitation human trafficking
how could this change the future of porn
he joins me now alongside feminist
writer and campaigner Julie
bindle Sam and Julie welcome to
spectator TV now Sam for coffee house
this week you've written about the rise
of AI porn can you explain what you mean
by AI porn and how fast that rise has
been well it's it's the sort of
pornography of the no humans involved
variety where what AI has become really
really good at it turns out it's kind of
creating out of a compost of billions of
images and God knows you know the
internet is 80% porn anyway it's got all
these billions of images available to it
and it trains the AI to create new
images lifelike um you know lifelike
scenes and videos involving you know
essentially completely generated people
um I mean actually what sparked my
interest in it this week was that there
was a piece in I think I think the Wall
Street Journal saying that this stuff
was being used for blackmail um in the
sense that people you know this of old
revenge porn thing people say I've got
an intimate compromising photograph of
you or a video of you having sex I'm
going to send it to all your friends
unless you give me a Bitcoin or I'm
going to shame you or bully you with it
and what had happened is that now ai can
generate effectively fake nudes of real
people by either you know taking clothed
photographs of them and extrapolating
from that or simply kind of seamlessly
putting their face onto existing
pornographic footage um so it's kind of
it's quite alarming what the technology
can do and according to the Wall Street
Journal it's causing the people on the
receiving end of this some real distress
now Julie you spent so much of your life
campaigning against porn uh and violence
against women and girls what do you make
off this rise of AI
porn well I disagree with some that it's
a porn with no humans involved and I'll
just give another another example of why
I think that this causes real harm um
and in fact is is is way more Insidious
in many ways than we could imagine I was
at a few years ago I went to the LA porn
Awards didn't win anything but there ago
I was reporting on it and there was um
there was a new product on sale at the
time which was sex dolls very realistic
porn dolls sex dolls which whatever you
want to call them made um a very like
life images of famous female porn actors
that men could buy so that they are just
effectively having sex with violating
abusing the Effigy of a real person and
some of the porn actors told me that
they found it really distressing there
was nothing that could do about it now
if we look at AI generated porn it's not
just being used for blackmail it's also
being used as sex therapy which is the
most abor thing that I can imagine
inagine first of all the notion that
there are these men who are hardwired as
so-called pedophiles which is nonsense
it's a cultural uh Norm not a hardwire
genetic there's no there's no pedophile
Gene um
so what what the AI creators or the AI
apologists are saying is that if you
actually create child abuse imagery that
doesn't involve real harm to real
children these men will be satisfied as
though there are are these men that have
a craving for sex with children that has
to be satisfied in a way that the
alcoholic has to have a drink this is a
myth and it seeks to just normalize the
suedes of men that do see out child
abuse imagery from the kind of school
girl in a uniform whether she's 16 18 or
14 through to hardcore stuff and
actually using AI child abuse imagery is
like pouring petrol on an already
flaming fire because what in fact it
does is desensitizes men because it
usually almost always is men to the
notion that children even babies are
being sexually abused because they can
justify by saying well of course I'm not
really harming children but I'm curious
because the way the porn trade Works its
money model is to push more and more
harder harder raise the bar all the time
so more money is spent but another thing
is and this perhaps is the most
concerning that men have already made
excuse if they are found with child
abuse imagery to say well of course
these are AI created or at least that's
what I was told and AI creators of child
abuse imagery or the illegal horn which
would be illegal if it's been done to
real women uh in real time could also
Market it as though this is AI generated
so all it does is drive more traffic to
the most abusive imagery and absolutely
feels the fire already raging Sam no I'm
I'm intrigued by that I don't think I
was was intending to imply when I said
no humans involved that this was you
know all Ticky boo and I think I Julie
maybe I'm getting ahead of myself we
we're talking about images of child
abuse for instance I mean it struck
me that there's sort of two ends to this
and you you know and obviously yield to
you and your expertise and how they
connect one of which is it seems to me
that you know the real life abuse that
takes place in the creation of old
school slow food porn which you have
admirably made it you know your business
to find out about and investigate and
expose over many many
years and the other is what you
described the fuel on the fire that the
imagery helps to cultivate to normalize
to encourage appetites and they are
often appetites for more and more
extreme material for you know the taboo
I mean there does seem to be a thing
whereby the more taboo something is the
more people or some people are going to
find it sexy and that therefore the you
know that's why the the sort of Baseline
constantly moving and it struck me as a
thought experiment what I was writing
about in my piece was look if a lot of
mainstream pornography and I'm leaving
to one side for a second if you like
rape and child rape and that sort of
really extreme end of it but if the you
know your basic basic work a day
ordinary vanilla filth such as it is
were to be generated so cheaply and
effectively by
AI would that have at least at one end
of this this two-ended issue um the
effect of essentially removing some of
the market for the more
expensive real person exploitative
you know traditional porn if you like
where people are setting up Studios
they're trafficking and exploiting very
often you know the performers there you
know there's all sorts of risk and
consent issues and you know there's a
lot a lot of really really nasty stuff
goes on in the real world as a result
would do you think you know leaving
aside the question of the appetites that
the extreme staff might Fu which I'm
very much not brushing aside but leaving
that to one
side is there a case that you know AI
porn might help to put a dent in an
industry that does an awful lot of real
world harm well first of all Sam I
wasn't for a second thinking that you
were actually advocating for more AI
porn that isn't how I read the piece at
all in fact I thought it was a very very
carefully argued piece that asked some
absolutely crucial questions and I
thought it was it was very very uh
nuanced and responsibly written um but
first of all the best business model
that the porn industry ever came up with
was free porn um which actually puts a
dent in the argument about AI porn put
in a dent in the kind of pay for
business because what free porn did was
it normalized the use of porn for those
that were not thinking of themselves at
that time as porn consumers and that
included children so 11-year-old boys or
it included men who aren't disrespectful
of women who do have quite healthy real
life sex lives um with real life women
that's consensual but who thought well
I'll give it a bit of a whirl and of
course they're not going to put their
credit card um into the um the app
they're going to just start off on the
free porn and then of course and I don't
buy the addiction model I disagree with
those feminists that suggest that it's
addictive I do think that it gets
compulsive and I know the way that the
business model pushes and pushes just
that kind of more and more extreme their
Al your algorithms are very carefully
monitored and then you given something a
bit more risque or a bit more close to
illegality a bit more close to looking
as though it might be child abuse imagry
and then of course the credit cards can
come out so I think that that's that's a
problem with the arguments about AI um
because what AI will do is exactly what
um legal brothel for example at the
other side of the sex trade do for the
illegal industry it acts as a smoke
screen it acts as a driver and it acts
as a Gateway now not a Gateway in the
that people argue that cannabis is a
gateway to heroin I don't buy that at
all what I mean is that because there
isn't and this is my main argument there
isn't such a thing as a pedophile the
medical model that's hardwired to want
to have sex with children or rape
children rather this means that it's a
cultural drive and the more we normalize
it and of course AI will will rely it B
its business will rely on child abuse
imagry within the next 5 years it will
be almost totally child abuse imry
so we're we're driving more and more men
to the more normalized version and as I
say an excuse that they thought it was
all just Ai and no child was could
possibly have been harmed uh in the
meantime and Sam can I come in here
because um you also suggest that this is
a genie out of the bottle so do you
think that nothing can be done basically
to regulate this to turn back the tide
it seems to me if you look at the
world's track record you know country by
country internationally regulating
almost anything on the internet um it's
pretty poor I mean you know the the
protocols the Elders of Zion are still
zooming around the internet the um you
know fake news has proliferated rather
than disappearing this old idea that
sunlight is the best disinfectant and a
completely open internet will mean that
you know that everything will be
transparent and we'll all be a to see
the truth turned out to be the exact
opposite of the truth so you know if we
can't get rid of you know fake gandi
quotes um the chances that we can get
rid of you know artificially
generated which can be done at scale of
course you know an AI can produce a you
know hour and a half long porn film I'm
assuming um or certainly will soon be
able to in a matter of moments and it
will be able to change it and it will be
able to put whoever you want in it and
it will be you know the idea that the
slow laborious business of copyright law
and takedowns and International jur
dictions is going to be able to handle
this seems to me to be a very very
optimistic one Julie you must be very
concerned about that because at least in
the current form of the porn industry
you've got these major Studios you've
got the major companies youve got the
major websites that you can kind of
track but what we're seeing here is you
know kids teenagers and just your
average normal people taking this
technology and they have the capability
of creating that well Sam's absolutely
right you know the the internet is not
not pable but it is very difficult to do
so but there has to be the willingness
also I mean in countries like Sweden and
Norway and various others where um for
example the purchase of sex prostituted
sex has been criminalized police have
got pretty good at having a look on the
internet and tracking down gangs of
pimps and uh sexual exploitation in
general and I think that they could do
more than they're doing and I'm not a
kind of ban it all you know make make it
all illegal because actually we started
off from the point where there is a
proliferation and we need to think much
more closely about the way that we have
normalized um sexual abuse imagery in
general not just of children but of
adult women and men across the board and
what that means in terms of
relationships what it means in terms of
consensual sexual encounters when in
fact sex dolls porn dolls are becoming
way more um you know normalized
throughout that kind of industry but I
just want to
flip it the other way around in a way
because we've got
AI obviously because of
technological progress at the end of um
a Spate of of of pornography being
available pretty much everywhere I mean
porn now actually drives technology
rather than the other way around where
we now have permission for more violent
degrading abusive rape porn um gagging
choking the kind of porn that that is is
way way more kind of acceptable than it
was 20 years ago partly because the
pornographers tested the market by using
cartoon imagery and if we think about
Hustler the infamous cover of Hustler
Magazine with a cartoon image of a woman
being put head first through a meat
grinder to
um you know to to depict her as just a
piece of meat that was there as you know
or a set of orisses for men to do what
they wanted with it was extremely
effective Ive there are other images
that were tried um and tested in Playboy
which I can't even describe on this um
podcast because it's it's too
distressing which because it was cartoon
form they got away with it now we're in
a situation where AI will be able to go
way way further and remember many men
many consumers of Hardcore violent porn
enjoy their subject being abused they
enjoy the s IC pleasure they want to see
them hurt and the thing about an AI
image an AI model is they know that
there's no pain being felt and that that
is something that will drive them back
and forth from AI back to the porn
involving real life women being abused
on set now Julie what about the role of
payment systems and the companies like
uh MasterCard Visa PayPal for example
because I've read that their support uh
and they're cutting off of their support
for websites like PornHub have actually
really damaged pornhub's traffic because
payment companies deemed what they were
doing as a bit too extreme and that has
actually had quite a real impact so is
that the way to regulate the industry it
absolutely could and in fact if you look
at what happened a couple of years ago
with mindgeek and PornHub which is one
of the uh sites that uh mindgeek own
biggest porn site porn business on the
planet it was really successful when
after a huge huge outcry from those of
us that do campaign to expose porn's
reality the hell of it where there were
countless videos uploaded of girls not
just women girls being raped and
otherwise abused when that all came out
thanks to the campaigning and the
exposure several big credit card
companies bowed to pressure and said
okay we won't accept payments through
PornHub it needs to clean up its act and
this is unacceptable and then of course
bit by bit it's crept back so that now
the big credit card companies are now
accepting payment so we need to keep the
pressure on but I think practically
that's the only thing we can do there's
no resources in policing and there's no
willingness and most police officers
male police offices are consuming porn
quite frankly and not only that but what
hurts the pornographers is the cash
being um you know that their revenue is
threatened in any way what turns
pornographers on is not the sex it's the
cash and that's where we need to to
direct all our efforts Julie you'll have
chapter and verse on this but I remember
there was a kind of really shocking
thing that broke through about PornHub
that people started looking to its
system for flagging images of abuse
trafficked people stolen images rape all
these you underage underage participants
and there was a whole thing where I
think they had literally one person for
this entire site and you'll remind me if
I'm getting this right who was
supposedly in charge of takedowns and
nothing would be brought to their
attention unless it had already been
flagged three times by three separate
people regardless of what it was is that
right am I getting that right that
that's exactly right I can't remember if
it was one person or one and a half
people on a job share but it was a
scandal and I interviewed a a young
woman who when she was 15 was gang rate
and that that video of her gang rate was
up on PornHub and it was only after
years of her complaining begging writing
letters emailing getting her friends and
her parents to do so that finally a
lawyer came on board sent a legal letter
uh and they decided to take the um the
video down and that was some time that
she had to fight for that to happen that
should be instant and day Reger and they
can also of course filter they can vet
these videos in in reality mind geek
PornHub and and these big sites they
know that those rape videos Drive
traffic
they know that they do this is not there
is no such thing as ethical porn there
is some porn that's less bad than other
porn genres but there is no ethical porn
and there is no ethical porn industry
Julie and Sam that's all we have time
for today thank you so much for joining
spectator
TV that's it for this week once again if
you do enjoy spectator TV subscribe to
our YouTube channel just click the
Subscribe button at the bottom of this
video and tap the Bell icon so you never
miss an episode I'd also like to thank
our sponsors cancord genuity wealth
management cancord are experienced
wealth planners and investment managers
who offer unwavering support during
challenging times visit candy wealth.com
for more information thanks again for
watching and join us again next
[Music]
week